what's a good word for people like that
you know like um megalomaniac
i mean megalomaniac is usually usually
kind of the thing right
it's people who think that they have the
capacity to just step in and do
good like and it's like the bad guy in
the movie
they know how to or yeah i'm glad you
brought that up
isn't that film just a bit on the nose
yeah like they even make the my fair
lady reference what's that
okay so you you know you know the story
my fair lady right it was like a woman
was like a
[ __ ] or something yeah yeah eliza
doolittle
and so this is written by george bernard
shaw it was actually originally titled
pygmalion and
modeled after the pygmalion myth but we
don't have to go into pygmalion um
so eliza doolittle is this [ __ ]
basically
uh and these two rich guys find her and
they're like
i have a bet you know and they're gonna
they're gonna bring her in
and teach her her manners well enough to
fake it
and if she can get to the end of this
you know fancy dinner at the end of a
certain amount of time
and convince everybody that she's not
basically
a flower girl which i think is what it
actually is she's selling flowers or
something and that's of course a symbol
for something
um then you know one or the other wins
the bet and it's all this gentleman's
bet or whatever
and so that's what my fair lady is about
so that was written though by george
bernard shaw who is the leader of the
fabian socialists
which had the crest of a wolf in sheep's
clothing
and it had the explicit uh agenda if you
could look up there they have a stained
glass window it's very famous called the
the fabian glass or the fabian window
and uh it actually says something
it shows the world heated up on a forge
set on an anvil and they're hitting it
with hammers and one of the people
hitting it is george bernard shaw
and it's like heat it up and remold it
to the
heart's desire or something like that so
they're trying to reshape the world and
they were socialist and the goal was
incremental sneaking and of socialism
wolf and sheep's clothing so that people
don't realize what you're doing
it says remold it nearer to the heart's
desire yeah that's what it says that's
right pray devoutly hammer stoutly wow
yeah so this is this is actually a
really famous piece of glass the the
the fabian society is not well known now
it i think still exists it spun off the
labor party in the uk
and probably the other labor parties it
also spun off the london school of
economics which is probably it's kind of
main operating base
of think tanks now and
the reference like at the very beginning
of kingsman you know you have
again this kind of like rough neck essex
cockney kid right and he's just like all
kinds of in trouble because he grew up
without his dad
his dad died in the thing and uh he has
a special like kingsman thing if he ever
gets in trouble and he's always going
around and horsing around getting in
trouble he's and he's a his
foul mouth it's really kind of funny the
way he talks you know
eggsy is his name yeah and then he ends
up getting in trouble
and he calls and it's like these
gentlemen appear and now they're going
to make him into
a gentleman warrior yeah secret service
agent gentlemen spy
and you know the movie's hilarious it's
really worth watching it's it's like a
semi's i don't know it's not even
semi-serious it's spoof off of like
james bond type stuff
it's it's pretty serious but it's pretty
serious too yeah but like it kind of
it plays into the silliness of the
gentleman's bio right and so the theme
of the first
there's two of the two films and the
theme of the first film though you have
uh is it samuel jackson yeah is playing
this
cell phone company big tech mogul
um vincent valentine or something
something valentine
uh i forgot his first name and he
basically has decided that we are the
virus and the planet is going to die
from global
global warming and so he devises this
technology
that he will that can make people go
insane and kill each other
if they hear a noise and so what he
offers is everybody in the world gets
free cell phones free sim cards
free internet forever or whatever so
everybody goes to get their free sim
cards and then he plays the sound when
everybody has them
and everybody starts killing each other
everywhere they are and uh
to kill to bring down the global
population so that and it's like
but the [ __ ] in this movie stops him
and saves all the people well that's
right that's exactly right so is that
kind of like
defying shaw's you know story
i mean i watch this and i'm just i mean
but the point of course i just brought
up shaw because
they they referenced the movie right
right and so the
or the reference the the play i should
say my fair lady what i mean is
in the movie the bad guy is the guy who
wants to kill all the people to stop
global warming
correct using a high-tech media device
right makes people crazy which is
super on the nose exactly and the the
good guy is the regular person
who didn't want to be involved and got
dragged in and found an opportunity and
then says i'm going to stop these people
and save
the ones that i love oh right a regular
guy who along the way learns man
manners maketh man yeah right so that's
like their like little line
of the gentleman warrior or spy or
whatever but yeah so
the the question i watch this and i'm
like did the people who wrote this film
know like they made the my fair lady
reference did they know about the fabian
socialist the plan of the fabian
socialists they know where this is like
what could be going on here are they
tapped into the idea that we're using
media devices like that in our pocket
it's not noisy this is social media to
drive ourselves nuts and hate each other
have you seen um what's that uh what's
that tv show
the the the virus one oh uh utopia
utopia yeah you've seen utopia i have
not but
they can't they want to know why they
canceled it uh two on their nose yep
yep whoa the show is about a
uh there's these people and spoiler
alert it's an old show but they remade
it on amazon the amazon remake
apparently got cancelled because it was
two on the nose
uh let me explain that but you know let
me explain
they there's a comic book and in the
comic there's clues to what's really
going on
to put it simply a piece of visual
entertainment
gives a group of people for knowledge as
to what's really going on and what's
really going to happen
as it turns out this tech mogul guy
who thinks that we're overpopulated and
the planet is destroying itself
stage is a pandemic and then offers up
everybody a vaccine
which sterilizes them and they cancelled
it because they were like
yeah no and so the point was conspiracy
theorists were saying
a piece of visual entertainment that we
can watch
is talking about a virus that's being
staged you know that's that where a tech
mogul is pushing a vaccine
little on the nose with what's going on
right now and so you you have it you
have a show
they're reading a comic learning the
future or what's the pl what the plan is
the code names tech mogul well we got a
bill gates we got a covet 19 we got a
vaccine
program and we got it free for everybody
and so they were like you know stuff
that's not the show
yeah well the original version of it
actually was back in like i think 2011
or something in the uk
yeah i mean so i mean life imitates art
i guess do you ever see that video game
plague inc
plague incorporated it was like the
object it's still super popular yeah
well it got banned in china
right after kovid they banned it but the
point of the game is you're playing as a
virus or a pathogen of some sort and you
want to infect all of humanity and
destroy them
and so after china banned the game some
time went by they were like we feel
really bad about this they just
released their expansion the cure so now
you play as a doctor trying to vaccinate
and
stop the the plague uh it's free for
everyone until kovitz done by the way
they said
yeah so good bad i don't know but super
keyed into the manipulation of media
that's for sure you know there's a
gender studies paper that's titled
women's studies as a virus
right is that yours i know
no this one's real it's by michael
carger and brianne fawz
and they actually argue that the virus
makes the ideal metaphor for feminist
and
women's studies and gender studies
pedagogy and they say that
what what it should be is that people
are being infected in their disciplines
and
by maybe minoring in the subject or
whatever and then going off into
graduate school to infect other
disciplines
and then they compare themselves i kid
you not they compare themselves
favorably to
all of hiv ebola and cancer
wow they compare their own discipline
favorably they say
hiv is is immune suppressing and so you
want to be you have to take up
steps that make you immune suppressing
because it's a very effective virus
ebola is extraordinarily powerful and
dangerous and contagious
and cancer represents i'm not joking
they talk about viruses entering cells
maybe like the hpv or whatever and
changing the dna in the cell
and then that leads to cancer and they
said that represents permanent
transformational change of disciplines
and and other departments and other
walks of life and affinities
cancer that's how they want a permanent
you know i wish i would they literally
call themselves cancer hiv and ebola
wow i wish the grand conspiracies were
real sometimes because life's not boring
i mean it's like and it's probably just
you look for patterns i think they are
sometimes that's the crazy part yeah
like gulf of tonka and we know that yeah
we do know that for a fact i mean for
admission anyway
yeah mostly for i don't know i think
there is still some you know
pushback sometimes these crazy
conspiracies are real which makes life
worth living i mean it's just so
interesting
it also makes life very dangerous if you
look into certain things like state
street
blackrock and uh what's that other big
investment firm there's like three
investment firms that run the earth
basically right
uh black stu it's a black the real
government yeah yeah at some point and
this is true a lot of people realize
because i've actually
i've actually talked to uh politicians
who've said this it's called vanguard
vanguard black rock and states vanguard
vanguard biggest investment firm in the
world
i've actually met politicians who say
it's sometimes better to have the power
in the shadows than it is to be the
public face
and so a lot of politicians are
performative they're there to entertain
and keep stability in the sense that
like it's it's almost like
you know with the coliseum of rome
people were suffering they were hungry
there was chaos there was corruption so
give them fights and throw bread up
bread in circuses right
well now they're effectively doing that
in congress you'd see for the longest
time
these politicians yelling like you know
my colleague over there across the aisle
just hates everybody and i'm sick of it
and then once it's over like you see the
camera is like
you know the the the the actual news
network would pull away but actually
on in in the senate they'd like walk
like nobody's watching it yeah you'd
watch them shake hands and grab a drink
together and be hanging out and laughing
and it was like all a performance
because there are people they keep the
the people in this country divided
to a certain degree and i i you know
maybe it's on purpose maybe it's not but
it's actually what this what the machine
does
whether whether these politicians
intentionally do it i'm sure a lot of
people would say they would
the machine does it regardless right the
the city people and the rural people
are divided even in red states blue and
like
small towns are blue it's the weirdest
thing i was in rural west virginia
and i drove through a tiny town and it
was all critical race theory
and i was like i just drove like a mile
away it was all trump
signs but in a small town where you had
proximity more density
it was like black lives matter flags and
stuff so you think they're playing
performance these politicians because
it's too dangerous to go deep on like
the real issues
no the real companies like vanguard i
think i think no i think the problem is
they don't care they don't pay attention
that might be true so
it's an easy opportunity for those with
massive power to just keep gaining power
and one will stop them i mean kennedy
got killed i don't know if it was a
political coup or not
but the dude was speaking out against
the military-industrial complex and got
killed
that sucked so in not since have any
president ever come out trumps the
military yeah he did a little absolutely
not really no he didn't really yeah i
mean a little bit weapons deal he
acknowledged it but he didn't like do
anything he wasn't saying i'm gonna
break it up
he was all in favor of the weapons deals
because of the money but he's not in
favor of the war because he promised to
end it
and so it wasn't perhaps the uh uh
if you believe in the conspiracies it
wasn't a kill-worthy thing it was like
he's still selling our weapons we're
getting money
how do we sell more if he's not using
them you know what i mean so they didn't
like that they wanted more war
but he wasn't like overtly like i'm
gonna break up the military industrial
complex like kennedy said he was very
overt about it well
fearless thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you